dijo a las afueras del estadio azteca de
ciudad de mexico el pasado fin de semana
los fanáticos que fueron a ver el
partido de clasificación de la selección
nacional contra costa rica fueron
recibidos con algunos novedosos
requisitos de entrada un cuestionario
especial un código qr personalizado y
una serie de advertencia a partir de
ahora quien sea sorprendido coreando
cánticos homófobos se enfrenta a una
prohibición de cinco años para entrar al
estadio ya estamos hartos de que nos
están multando de que nos estén
suspendiendo si pueden ingresar a los
partidos y sobre todo yo creo que ya es
momento de tener un buen comportamiento
de no discriminar y también cero
violencia durante las últimas dos
décadas corear jerga despectiva contra
los porteros del equipo contrario se ha
convertido en una costumbre indecorosa
en las gradas mexicanas desde 2015 la
federación mexicana de fútbol ha sido
multada unas 15 veces por la fifa por
reincidencia pero ahora se está
adoptando un enfoque de tolerancia cero'
una medida bien recibida por la
floreciente liga de fútbol el eje más de
ciudad de méxico mientras el país se
prepara para compartir las funciones de
anfitrión con eeuu y canadá para la copa
del mundo de 2026 entonces tenemos que
estar preparados como cultura porque en
el próximo año que este año que termina
el mundial y el próximo año que inicia
nuestro proceso tenemos que abrirnos al
mundo no y decir venga esto es méxico y
en méxico se respeta no se apoya el
partido del domingo estaba destinado a
jugarse en un estadio vacío como castigo
por los cánticos homófobos antes de que
gméxico apelará con éxito la decisión de
la fifa el resultado final en sí mismo
un símbolo de igualdad fue un empate de
0 a 0